[Music]
on this monday night the consequences
for canada
of pfizer's vaccine production reduction
that's going to be a massive massive
impact how provinces are coping with a
shortage of shots
covet 19 rages through an ontario care
home the fears the new variant is to
blame
the next u.s president's plan to kybash
keystone xl
the ramifications for alberta and what
it means for canada u.s relations
and pro athletes bouncing off the walls
i don't think i can swing my racket and
go through when competing requires
quarantining and creative ways to train
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the pressure
building on canada's health care system
a delay in promised vaccine doses is
coupled with concern about how quickly
new more
contagious variants of covid19 are
spreading
at least 25 cases of the highly
transmissible uk variant have now been
detected in canada most are in ontario
where 15 cases have now been confirmed
the latest one is not linked to travel
that is evidence
it's spreading within the community
this is concerning to all of us
especially as the data indicates that
this variant
may be spread about 56 percent more
easily
than other variants
and that could change the game there is
no evidence the variants make people
more severely ill
but because they spread so much faster
the case rate could skyrocket
hospitals already over capacity would
need help
today it was announced a newly built
hospital in vaughan ontario will act as
an overflow providing 185 additional
beds including
over 35 spots for people needing
critical care
it's expected the bulk of them will be
covered patients
with many of our hospital icu's
approaching full capacity or beyond
this new hospital it's relief it's added
capacity
for all those heroes who are stretched
to the limit right now
that new hospital doesn't open till
february 7th contingencies also have to
be made
for the shortage of pfizer biontech
vaccines alberta now says it will be out
of doses by tomorrow
as abigail beeman explains all the
provinces are coming up with strategies
on how to cope just hours after
toronto's first
mass vaccination center outside a
hospital opened monday
we have now been advised by the province
that we will only be able to operate
this proof of concept
clinic for an initial five days they're
now canceling appointments due to the
pfizer biontech vaccine delay
as the company works to ramp up
production in europe
very disappointing to all of our city
that's going to be a massive massive
impact
ontario stopped reserving doses after
coming under fire
now do we wish we would have held back a
little more sure sure we do
in ontario the focus remains on
vaccinating long-term care residents
staff and essential caregivers while
alberta announced it finished all
long-term care home vaccinations i
believe makes alberta the first province
in the country
to complete the first dose vaccine
rollout for this
important and highly vulnerable
population but due to the pfizer delay
jason kenney announced they're not
booking any more
first dose appointments first nations
and metis people over 65 and
all seniors over 75 are next on the list
they'll now have to wait i'm deeply
disappointed
at the situation that we are now facing
thankfully
we did not need to cancel any
appointments a vaccine supersite opened
monday in brandon manitoba officials
spent the weekend crunching numbers and
believe they can schedule another 4
thousand appointments province wide
even with the shortfall we're being told
that we're going to be
getting about 28 000 fewer doses over
the next four
weeks frustration too as the european
union is expected to get back to its
regular supply schedule from pfizer next
week
just when canada is expected to see the
biggest lag
in a statement to global news in
response pfizer says specific
percentage allocations may fluctuate but
they expect it all to balance out by the
end
of the first quarter abigail beeman
global news
ottawa the world health organization is
warning the world is on the brink of
what it calls a catastrophic
moral failure over equitable access to
covet 19 vaccines
the head of the who says wealthy nations
have a me first
attitude and that's leaving the world's
most vulnerable at risk
ultimately these actions will
only prolong the pandemic
prolong our pain
the restrictions needed to contain it
and human and economic suffering
the head of the world health
organization says more than 39 million
vaccine doses have been administered
in at least 49 high-income countries
compared with just
25 shots in one low income country
guinea is the only lower income country
to administer any doses so far
using russia's sputnik 5 vaccine
there is concern the uk variant might be
behind a severe outbreak at an ontario
long-term care
facility roberta place in barrie ontario
more than 100 positive cases have been
confirmed in residence and staff there
and
the death toll is climbing morgan
campbell
reports every monday debbie grigg visits
an assessment center to get tested for
covet 19.
she does this so she can see her 75 year
old mother
who lives in a long-term care home in
berry she lives in constant fear of
losing her mother
to the deadly virus anytime i see the
number come up i just dread to answer
the phone
griggs's mother is one of more than 100
residents under lockdown
at roberta place at least 10 residents
here have died from the novel
coronavirus
since an outbreak was declared on
january 8th an additional 60 residents
have been diagnosed
in addition to more than 50 staff
members four family doctors from the
area
are volunteering their time and
assisting with medical care
one of those doctors is kelly wright who
believes the virus may be a mutated
variant
and what we've been told in the
literature is that
that variant is quite virulent meaning
that the transmission rate is quite
quite quick so i mean our clinical
suspicion is that it
might be that the simcoe muskoka
district health unit
is currently testing swaps from the
facility to determine
if the virus is in fact a variant a
variant of the virus is showing up in
long-term care homes to the south
in toronto the understanding is that
they are
more transmissible than some of the
earlier variants that we were seeing
here
in toronto and in ontario while the
variant is concerning
treatment and containment options remain
the same according to those
working the front lines it doesn't
change our approach to the disease
because the symptoms present the same
way in the course of treatment and
management
of symptoms is unchanged the federal
government has
allocated 70 million in funding for the
canadian red cross to
help assist homes in need they have been
deployed to
roberta place the home has also received
support from the royal victoria hospital
and soldiers memorial in aurelia
assistance
that has been welcomed by girlette
health services
which operates the home while there may
be assistance
families on the sidelines feel helpless
it is very worrisome it's very scary and
it's very heartbreaking
saturday public health administered 71
vaccines to residents and staff
morgan campbell global news
the countdown is on to inauguration day
in washington d.c
joe biden will take office on wednesday
protected by the biggest security
operation
in history the risk is not just of a
repeat of the political violence when
pro-trump supporters stormed the capitol
there's also fear of a threat from
within and tonight the fbi
is vetting the thousands of troops being
brought in to guard the inauguration
jackson proskow explains in these tense
hours before joe biden's inauguration
washington is on edge
a fire near the capitol briefly
triggered a lockdown
forcing the evacuation of the
inauguration platform where a dress
rehearsal for wednesday's swearing in
was underway
the number of national guard troops
deployed in washington reached 25
thousand
those members are undergoing background
checks to root out potential extremists
in their ranks
a possible threat from within in
coordination with the secret service and
the fbi they're screening all the
personnel that are coming in
all the while the security perimeter
around the capitol is expanding
to the point that spectators won't be
able to get anywhere close to
wednesday's swearing in
it is a deterrence for people are going
to do bad things this is to keep people
safe and understand that we are here for
the american people
objection to counting electoral votes of
the state of arizona
new video from the new yorker shows the
ferocity of the capital siege
the rioters seemed to believe they had
the backing of trump and his republican
allies
in their attempt to disrupt the
electoral college vote count
yet on his final monday in the white
house the president is in seclusion
issuing a flurry of executive orders
doing nothing to end the lie about a
stolen election
words that might calm his supporters and
a nation
on edge tomorrow is trump's final full
day in office as
president it's not clear if he'll break
his nearly week-long seclusion and
appear before the cameras
it's not clear if he'll issue a flurry
of last-minute pardons as many have
expected
he spent today issuing a number of final
executive orders
before he heads off to florida which is
where he'll spend his time after he
leaves office
donna all right jackson prosco in
washington thanks
albertus premier is looking for federal
help to try to keep the keystone xl
pipeline expansion alive
it is on life support again
president-elect joe biden has long
promised he would cancel the permit for
the pipeline project and now
it appears it is one of the first things
he will do when he's inaugurated on
wednesday
premier kenny invested 1.5 billion
dollars in the project
last year now he's scrambling to come up
with a strategy to deal with the fallout
heather urix west reports a little more
than a week before
joe biden emerged as the presumed
democratic presidential nominee
alberta's premier placed a bet it is a
solid bet that will produce a handsome
return for albertans
and it will rescue the future of our
energy industry
a 1.5 billion dollar purchase stake in
tc energy's keystone xl pipeline
as well as six billion dollars in loan
guarantees
it was so much money to put on a project
that it was entirely foreseeable that it
would be cancelled
i mean that's one of the things that
vice president biden campaigned on
reports that the now u.s president-elect
plans to kill keystone on day one
may not be surprising to some but
alberta's premier says construction on
the pipeline was already well
underway this is with i believe without
precedent
for an american administration
retroactively
to seek to cancel a piece of
infrastructure
this border crossing that already exists
by getting pipes in the ground and
taking steps to improve the industry's
environmental performance
both the alberta government and the
industry had hoped to see the project
forge ahead
problem is the perception is so strong
in the u.s and keystone is such a flash
point that i don't think any of that's
going to matter
but for a premier that campaigned on
jobs economy and pipelines
the political cost of losing keystone
could be great
this is another piece of bad news on top
of
what's been a couple of months of
extraordinarily bad news he's
uh in the basement in the polls he's the
lowest polling premier in the country
there is a certain
irony that the trans mountain pipeline
which was purchased by trudeau
will be built and the pipeline purchased
by jason kenney
won't be built that is unless the new
u.s president
can very quickly be convinced to change
his mind heather eurix west global news
calgary the leader of the federal
conservative party says he is starting
the process
to remove mp derrick sloane from the
caucus aaron o'toole says he was
outraged to learn sloan accepted a
campaign donation from a white
supremacist
in a statement today o'toole says derek
sloane's acceptance of a donation from a
well-known white supremacist is far
worse than a gross error of judgment or
failure
of due diligence o'toole says sloane an
mp from ontario will not be able to run
for the party
again the statement also says racism is
a disease of the soul
repugnant to our core values
coming up the pleas and the pressure can
anyone save keystone xl
by wednesday afternoon this week the
trump administration will be history and
joe biden will occupy the white house
a whole new team of people with new
priorities will be in charge of the
country that's our nearest neighbor
but don't expect a big honeymoon as eric
sorenson reports
irritants like keystone xl are already
emerging
behind the scenes the government of
canada is in contact with the biden
transition team
in a statement the minister of natural
resources reiterated ottawa's support
for keystone xl
adding we continue to make the case for
it to our american colleagues
the official opposition is calling on
the prime minister to reach out to joe
biden to keep keystone alive
reach into the new the new us incoming
administration
and make those contacts and ensure that
everybody understands how
important the north american economy
blocking keystone would not come as a
surprise
joe biden and his new climate czar john
kerry stood with president obama when he
turned down the project
five years ago president trump signed an
executive order to restart it
but biden's campaign made it clear last
year he would terminate it if elected
we need a unified national response to
climate change
and since the election biden has stacked
his cabinet with officials who opposed
keystone xl
and reflect a massive turn by washington
towards tackling climate change
defeating this threat is the fight of
our lifetimes a decision by joe biden is
expected as early as wednesday
after he is officially sworn in canadian
environmental advocates
say it should be viewed as an
opportunity for this country to embrace
a greener economy
we have a real chance because this is a
president
who has said president-elect who has
made it very clear
that the climate is going to be on the
top of his agenda
this is not a surprise given that global
markets are making it clearer
than ever that the jobs of the future
are jobs that help us fight the climate
crisis and that's where we need to make
investments pipelines aren't the only
challenge for ottawa
biden is also promoting buy american
policies that could impede canadian
trade
if it is something that we see as a
disadvantage for canada mr trudeau will
not hesitate to pick up the phone
and speak to mr biden and try to
negotiate a settlement in other words
whatever the hurdles in canada u.s
relations the prime minister is expected
to have a better working relationship
with the incoming president
than he had with the outgoing one eric
sorensen global news toronto
and global news will have live coverage
of the inauguration from washington dc
on wednesday morning at 11
eastern 8 pacific transport canada has
cleared boeing 737 max planes to fly
again
starting wednesday the approval follows
a 22-month
review launched after two deadly crashes
grounded the aircraft worldwide in 2019
the planes can fly if they meet
conditions including new software to
allow pilots to disable
a faulty stall warning it was central in
both the indonesia and ethiopian air
disasters
the federal transport minister says
transport canada has diligently
addressed all
the safety issues the first boeing 737
max flights are expected to resume in
canada on thursday
there's a major change to organ donation
in nova scotia and it's a first in north
america
it's called presumed consent most people
will be considered a potential organ
donor unless they
opt out there are exemptions including
people under the age of 19
those who don't have the capacity to
make their own decisions and
people who have lived in the province
less than a year it's estimated the
policy could boost organ donations in
nova scotia by 30 to 50 percent within
five years
according to the nova scotia government
a single organ donor can save up to
eight lives
ten people in atlanta canada die each
year waiting
for an organ transplant i had
a hopeful note in an urgent search for
minors trapped underground
he has survived a poisoning attempt with
a nerve agent accused russia's president
of trying to kill him and now
russian opposition leader alexei navalny
is behind bars in moscow
navalny was arrested on his return to
moscow from germany where he'd been
hospitalized after being poisoned in
siberia with a deadly nerve agent
a number of countries including canada
are calling for navalny's immediate
release
he has since released this video on
twitter calling on his supporters
to take to the streets in protest
there is renewed hope for a group of
miners trapped 600 meters underground in
china 12 men sent a note up through a
wire
cable telling rescuers don't stop trying
to reach us
they have little ventilation though one
of them is injured
rescuers have sent down supplies and
established a phone line
the group has been trapped since january
10th after an explosion destroyed exits
to the mine
10 other people are still missing a
california man who lived undetected in
chicago's o'hare international airport
for three months
was finally found and arrested for
trespassing the 36 year old arrived from
los angeles on october 19th
last year and stayed inside the secure
zone of the airport
he was apparently too afraid to fly
anywhere else because of covet 19.
his stay came to an end on saturday it
appears he snatched the id of an
operations manager
about a week after he arrived and when
two united airlines employees confronted
him
asking for his id they realized he
didn't match the picture on it
and called the police next how do
elite tennis players train for a
tournament while in isolation
you're watching global national
[Music]
the australian open tennis tournament is
going ahead but 72 players are going to
have to spend 14 days on their own
before it happens
they are confined to their hotel rooms
after some people on the flight over
tested positive for covet 19.
as crystal gamansing reports the strict
rules are serving up a dose of reality
to the elite players
all right done that was a tough one
lockdown workouts may be common but
imagine the world's
best tennis players trying to stay fit
in their hotel rooms
canada's vasik pospasil and about a
quarter of the field at the australian
open
will be relying on quarantine exercises
got the bike that's the bosu ball
everything that i did in the in the off
season uh which i had six
uh very good weeks of training it's um
not completely ruined but uh it's it's
not the same now
to stay sharp players are doing
everything imaginable
the number one player in the world novak
djokovic is taking a different approach
reportedly demanding players be moved to
private homes with tennis courts
and reduced quarantine times there's no
special treatment here people are being
treated
because a virus doesn't doesn't treat
you especially
so neither do we strict protocols were
attached to the open and
communicated with players to reduce the
risk of importing cases
i would say it's a minority of the
players that
um are kind of kicking up a fuss but a
lot of times
that minority are the loudest ones and
the most vocal two weeks of isolation
was
always a part of the deal players were
to get
five hours of outdoor training for those
on one of the charter flights with a
confirmed case
they're not permitted outside of their
rooms
one of those to test positive is sylvan
bruneau
the coach of canadian tennis champion
bianca and rescue
the canadians are taking it in stride
crystal gomencing global news london
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna freeze and we leave you
tonight with a scene that's going to
make kids across the country
envious
[Applause]
look at this it's a hockey rink in the
basement greg thompson and his wife
amanda built this calgary flames mini
dome for their kids
it started two winters ago as just a
rink but being flames fans they since
dressed it up to feel more like the
saddle dome
complete with a homemade jumbotron they
could be in the running for parents of
the year
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you